hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about uh NQ versus
es you know there was a question from
Henry III
Henry III in case you guys don't know it
uh was uh it was a king in England uh in
the 1200s I believe and you know he
posed the question
um do you have a preference between NQ
and yes I'm going to talk about some of
the differences in the way that I would
approach a market like NQ versus es but
before we jump in you know if you've
been enjoying these videos don't forget
to subscribe to the channel click the
notification Bell so you never miss a
new upload
um and if you find today's video helpful
be sure to hit the comment button and
leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway I love hearing your feedback
and you know that's what brings about
videos like this you know is your your
comments and feedback so let's go ahead
and get started with today's topic
alright so
you know Henry III says hey Mike new to
this channel do you work some time with
the NQ do I have a preference between NQ
and Es
actually I I do I prefer the es I just
find it's uh
I don't know how to describe it but I
find it a very mature Market it's a
market that like I say often distributes
volume
um
excellent right you don't have you know
big gaps in in trading you do in NASDAQ
now NASDAQ is is a different creature
um
it's a bit more uh wild in a sense you
know if you're familiar with NASDAQ but
this is a arranged based chart now on
e-minis right I'm comfortable with a
time-based chart or even a 10 range
chart uh just you know normal tick size
um you know on my footprint right one
take each level the problem is once you
start getting into NASDAQ right again
this this is now a 20 range chart okay
there's a lot of uh periods of
no trading right just because it's
um you know the price of NASDAQ
obviously is you know we're trading
around 14 000 something uh e-minis is
four thousand something so it's about
triple the price so you're getting more
volatility right when people fail to
realize sometimes is you know people say
oh you know like e-minis don't trade the
way they used to trade a few years ago
well yeah because now you have increased
volatility because now you know a few
years ago e-minis were trading you know
2 000 2500 now we're trading four
thousand five hundred so you know as you
start getting higher in price you're
going to tend to get more uh price
movements okay because the market is
really now looking for liquidity and on
a 20 range chart you know you're seeing
at each price level you've seen a lot of
zeros right five three two because you
often just get people sweeping through
price levels
to fill an order
okay now for us retail Traders right I
used to be on the institutional side but
for us retail Traders we don't think in
those terms because you know we're
trading you know one two three five Lots
in some cases you know a few people
trading you know 10 lots and oftentimes
you see the bid ask in the NASDAQ and
you know it could be 14 876 bid offered
at you know 14 877 so you're getting
oftentimes a wide bid ask as well you
know that's one of the things that sort
of causes
um you know sort of this lack of of
trading this lack of volume that's going
through at some price levels a lot of
zeros if I were to go to
you know a time-based chart I prefer
actually like a
less than one minute chart a 30 second
chart I think is fine to trade NASDAQ if
you're using
um you know the regular
tick size if you're not aggregating
ticks and even that right is is because
you know at the end of the day really
what you want to do is you want to take
advantage of the order flow as as
quickly as possible you know on a sort
of a normal trading day right now Friday
obviously we had uh Powell speaking at
Jackson Hole Market did have some extra
volatility come in but a 30 minute a 30
second chart rather is a little bit
about the way a one minute e-mini chart
would move in terms of price movements
now you still get some very big bars I
mean look at this bar here from um
14 9 13 and a quarter down to uh 14 900
double O so about a 13 Point move and
the next bar right back up to where we
started
um you know that's just the nature of
the market it's got more volatility than
than es now that's that's not to say
that NQ is a bad Market to trade no it's
a great Market to trade if you have the
balls the cojones to sort of sit through
you know imagine you're getting short
here and it looks like oh this is great
you know you're short here at 909
sells down to nine double O maybe you
gotta take profit down here at 8.99 and
a half and it just comes right back up
and to your entry price and then keeps
going up and you take a loss
um you get in my opinion I've
experienced more of of that where it's
like doesn't quite get it makes looks
like it's about to make a nice move
starts going in that direction doesn't
quite get to where I need it to be and
then just comes right back up to where I
got in and stops me out okay but again
you know if you're training a market
that in my opinion has more volatility
you're going to need wider stops to
begin with now this is a 30 second chart
Okay and like I said you know I don't
mind the 30 second chart on ES people
say well why 30 second chart because I I
know I sort of Base my
um trades like how long I've been in the
trade you know is it working out for me
or not and you know if a trade if I get
into a trade and it just sort of goes
sideways maybe a little bit in profit a
little bit against me taking some heat
for you know five minutes
10 minutes to me just that's my sign
just get out it's gonna not only just
you know
suck up some uh
actual trading Capital but emotional
Capital right you don't want to you know
say you get short
you know for example
you know I don't know right here right
Cloud 14884 for whatever reason doesn't
matter the reason just you know and it
starts going in your favor you know I
mean again maybe you got to take profit
here at 874 and it's just sort of
hanging around hanging around hanging
around you know you got one two three
four five six bars now again this is a
30 second chart so that's about three
minutes and then it pops back up right
but if if you notice it's not really
making that move that you're expecting
because remember you're trading order
flow
and you know when you when you're trying
to detect a big shift in the order flow
you're looking for a move to happen now
not Market goes sideways and then make
that shift because the order flow that
you're seeing coming in
has the most importance now as opposed
to you know five minutes ago you're not
gonna or in this case it's a minute 30
second chart so this is three minutes
later you're not gonna say well I had
that bearish order flow here but then
what about everything that's happening
in here right it could be going contrary
to your original idea for that trade now
just uh really quick if I were to switch
to a one minute chart it's like nearly
impossible to in my opinion really take
advantage of
the individual order flow now if I was
looking at a one minute chart really
what I'd be focusing on
is how value is developing
um you know at Price you know versus
price rather so for example because
remember right Friday we we had about a
300 Point sell off from this high all
the way down to you know the the low it
was in here 51 right so imagine right
it's great move if you take advantage of
and this is what I talk about the
importance of understanding value areas
right value areas that aren't traded
back into I don't need to know what I
mean I can expand this chart yeah I
don't need to know that oh the seven
laps traded here 11 traded here six
eleven if I'm just focusing on the value
right
so look at this okay I'm up here at the
high of the day I got the value area
coming in up here again I don't need to
focus on the individual volumes at each
level what I'm just focusing in on is
yeah I have a value area here developing
up at the high of the day
and the next bar doesn't even trade back
into that value now it goes into the
whole strategies of trading around value
but I know that this is a bearish sign
here just as it was here right just as
it is here
and you know that's my goal sign to be
getting short now
again I'm not looking for this move to
sell off you know 200 points 300 points
from that high all the way down to the
lows but look at where you see the value
that's not traded back into here
here all right do you see any bullish
value areas developing on this way down
no these are old ones from
um earlier another bearish one here
okay
and then we come down into this low
right here's a bearish one here here's a
bearish one who traded two bars later I
got my first bullish one here at around
you know 14 798 and a half down to 89.
and what happens this is basically where
the rally starts from right we get a
bearish one here another bearish one
here come back in test this value area
that's my support rally back up another
bearish one here bullish here
okay
bearish here
bearish bullish
bullish bearish coming back down into my
support
bullish here test it start working way
back up bearish and bullish
back up bullish bullish bullish 3 here
and keep working our way back up so I
mean you can see how the market
generates these areas and this is the
importance of trading around value right
whether it's a one minute chart a range
based chart
anything a volume based chart but you
know people always I do get this
question you know about trading NASDAQ
what should I look at you don't need you
know I I analyze NASDAQ much differently
than I analyze
es just because I mean look compare
these volumes here yeah 800 contracts
trade again this is a one minute chart
but it's very thin volumes so what I'm
doing in a sense is I'm sort of
aggregating the volume in a way in my
own way by looking at Value to
understand what's happening and really
what I'm paying attention to to focus on
is how Market is moving away from
perceived value in the market what I
perceive as value
and you know another way that I know
Traders are tackling NASDAQ to trade
successfully is um aggregating ticks and
what that means is
uh so for example right you can see it's
each price level right uh 14 850 14 850
and a quarter fourteen eight fifteen and
a half 14 850 three quarters uh fourteen
eight fifty one but it's only trading
you know what 18 uh 23 24 25 26 27 tick
contracts 27 contracts trade it's a lot
of zeros two one one two okay again like
I said you don't need to analyze every
single tick that goes through that's
what people sometimes are afraid of when
they start thinking of order flow but
you could aggregate ticks
it's a setting in here that we have tick
aggregation and what they do is they set
it to four
and basically it's going to take four
ticks and aggregate it into one level
and it just gives you a way to sort of I
guess manage the the chart a bit cleaner
right and actually when you do that you
know the one minute chart looks a bit
normal it looks a bit more like a
um
e-mini chart right then you could
analyze you know the zero prints
right you can start to analyze no but
again it's not a zero print at one level
it's a zero print at
you know four over four ticks okay
I mean if you were to add it on here
let's just take a look
um
thin print where are you here thin I'll
just make it zero
and give it a second here
zero zero zero zero two zeros up here
right it's going down forming your
bottom working your way back up zero
zero zero
so you know looking at NQ in es
I prefer me personally I prefer es over
NQ
that's just me I know a lot of Traders
are killing it in NQ
um again you know the bigger moves right
if you look you know those bigger moves
result in bigger profits but at the same
time you got to be able to manage your
risk
right you want to be able to take
advantage of those big moves but not get
hurt when it moves against you which is
something that can do uh pretty quickly
and easily
so again you know it basically it comes
down to the individual Trader and you
know what you want to look at you know
in NQ like I said it's got nice big
moves when they take place but at the
same time you get a lot of moves back
and forth that can frustrate you as a
Trader and again it's not just about
trading Capital that's at risk it's
emotional Capital at risk
so hopefully you guys uh get something
useful out of this video you know
um at the end of the day it's not about
trying to trade it just like me
all right it's about finding your way in
the markets right what Market is best
for you
what chart type is best for you because
people always ask me about chart types
Etc and again it's a personal preference
what
when you create a chart that you're
going to trade off of it has to be a
chart that
makes it easy for you to understand
what's taking place in the market
okay so again thanks for watching this
video I hope you enjoyed it be sure to
hit the Subscribe button if you haven't
already and hit the notification button
so you're going to be notified of any
new videos that I post in the future
thanks everyone bye bye